hello dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about how to lower
cortisol cortisol is a very destructive
hormone it's a stress hormone it makes
belly fat and there's a lot of theories
and mixed confusing ideas about cortisol
but I'm going to show you what is known
about cortisol so are hard to lower it
things that you can do things you can
avoid again it's made by the outside of
the adrenal gland on top of the kidney
and it's it reacts to stress so as you
age the opposing hormone called growth
hormone this is anti-aging goes down it
bottoms out at age 50 so in other words
the relative ratio of low growth hormone
to cortisol cortisol naturally goes
higher because it's unopposed it has
nothing to push it down so growth
anything that increases growth hormone
will help lower cortisol so growth
hormone is made by a gland pituitary
gland and it works with a liver and
guess what it activates during sleep so
if you can get more sleep or do
something to improve your sleep then you
will help yourself lower cortisol
whatever that means more sleep but not
necessarily taking a drug but doing it
naturally more sleep more growth hormone
less cortisol okay that's number one
number two IDF what's IGF in sunlight
growth factor what is that that is a
hormone that is very similar to growth
hormone
but it's produced by your liver so it's
released by the liver and it regulates
fat burning and it actually helps
regulates blood sugars when you're not
eating
so insulin regulate sugar when you're
eating IGF regulates triggers when
you're not eating and primarily when
you're sleeping so if you're just
grazing all day eating all day long and
never give your body a chance not to eat
then you will not trigger growth form
unless you're sleeping really good so I
recommend do two to three meals a day if
you really want to stimulate this and
not have too many
snacks and you'll find that your growth
your IGF will go up because anything
that increases growth hormone will also
increase this one here so these kind of
work together right here all right
number three Sun getting Sun on a
regular basis that's very very very
powerful to lower cortisol you go to the
beach you get Sun and you feel calmer
and then you take a nap sleep in Sun
lower cortisol so really what you need
to do is go on go to the beach for about
six months and get Sun and sleep Sun and
sleep and then I'm just kidding if you
can do that so we have Sun and sleep and
then vitamin D will also help as well
I've done other videos on this but you
need to get D 3 D 3 is really good to
help lower cortisol but realize that
when you take it get it in daily dosages
of about 10,000 international units if
you're getting about 15 to 20 minutes of
son of a day you don't need vitamin D
because you're going to get it from the
Sun but in the days that it's cloudy
take the d3 one 10,000 IU's but make
sure you're taking vitamin k2 with it I
created a video on that I'll put a link
down below because you need to get the
full scoop of what to take if you're
taking that much vitamin D just to
balance it out alright walking is way
better than any type of exercise to
lower cortisol long walks getting space
very therapeutic
acupressure that's one thing I do I
found that all stress accumulates and
you have to extract the stress manually
on the body so there is techniques to
help pull the stress out of your body so
your body can sleep up here so we do
acupressure to increase the sleep okay
potassium increase your potassium
normally in your body needs 4700
milligrams a day that's 7 to 10 cups of
salad a day this will help to balance
cortisol as well because potassium
supports part of the nervous system
helps recovery it's called the para
sympathetic nervous system okay that's
like that opposes the flight or fight
mechanism that's the anti cortisol thing
so potassium is very very good and
there's also another thing vitamin b1
very important make sure you get your b1
through nutritional yeast and not
synthetic vitamins nutritionally uses a
natural form of b1 and take a teaspoon
or a tablespoon put it in some plain
kefir or yogurt mix it all up a little
bit and then eat it you don't like the
taste put in peanut butter or something
like that applesauce but b1 is a very
very very very good thing and okay I
thought of another one calcium a little
calcium before bed calcium citrate
calcium lactate don't consume calcium
carbonate that's a very bad one but
calcium will also help before bed it
will help you sleep that's really really
beneficial to help that now things to
avoid well of course these are the
things that you can do these things
you shouldn't do and that would be you
know hang out with stressful people
people that bring you down there's two
types of people people that bring you up
and people that bring you down just to
avoid those negative covert hostile
people and that's important so basically
this is about changing your environment
with people and just mainly people
whether it's a stressful environment
that you live in job wise or whatever
just keep improving that because that
can severely affect your your general
state of being and the cortisol and if
you're living in an environment that's
constantly stressful you're gonna have a
heck of a time with this right here okay
so that's how you lower cortisol